[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Sievers
guten Abend Ihnen auch bei uns geht es
unter Wasser weiter wer hat Nord Stream
in die Luft gesprengt schon die Tatsache
dass es ein halbes Jahr nach dem
sabotageanschlag auf die Pipelines
fieberhafte Ermittlungen in gleich
mehreren Staaten gibt aber immer noch
keine offiziellen Antworten auf diese
Frage das lässt zunehmend Raum für
Spekulationen jetzt meldet heute die New
York Times als erste es gäbe
Erkenntnisse beim US-Geheimdienst die
daraufhin deuteten dass eine
proukrainische Gruppe hinter der Attacke
stecken könnte Gegner also des
russischen Präsidenten Claudia Bates mit
mehr
es ist eines der größten Rätsel im
Zusammenhang mit dem Krieg und nun gibt
es erste entscheidende Hinweise eine
pro-ukrainische Gruppe soll für die
Explosionen an den Nord Stream Pipelines
verantwortlich sein wer sie jedoch
beauftragt hat bleibt unklar eine
offizielle Stellungnahme der
US-Regierung zu dem Bericht gibt es
nicht heute nur so viel
einige der europäischen Partner
Deutschland Schweden Dänemark führen
Ermittlungen was passiert ist diese
Ermittlungen laufen noch und ich werde
Ihnen von hier aus nicht vorgreifen
in der Nacht zum 26 September 2022
zerrissen vier Explosionen die
nordstream 1 und 2 Pipelines schnell war
klar ein sabotageaktt die EU drohte
umgehend mit einer robusten Antwort laut
New York Times einen Angriff
möglicherweise ukrainischer und
russischer
antiputinakteure es gebe keine Beweise
dass die ukrainische Regierung dahinter
stecke auch sollen keine Briten oder
Amerikaner beteiligt gewesen sein in
ersten wilden Spekulationen hatte Kiew
die russische Regierung beschuldigt
Moskau seinerseits zeigte auf London
alles ohne Beweise
Sanktionen sind nicht genug für die
Angelsachsen jetzt wechseln Sie zu
Sabotage unglaublich aber wahr es ist ja
jedem klar wem das nützt und wer
profitiert hat es auch getan
kein Wort war sagt US-Präsident beiden
dazu der selbst ins Visier der
Spekulationen geriet zumal als er beim
Antrittsbesuch des deutschen
Bundeskanzlers sagte im Fall eines
russischen Einmarsches in die Ukraine
würde es keinen nordstream 2 mehr geben
die Reporterin hakt nach wie er das denn
bewerkstelligen wolle
ich verspreche Ihnen wir werden das
hinkriegen seine etwas geheimnisvolle
Antwort
am Abend bei einer Bürgersprechstunde in
Cottbus kein Wort zu den neuen Berichten
ein Sprecher der Regierung erklärte die
Untersuchungen liefen es gäbe noch kein
Ergebnis und auch
Nato-Generalsekretär Stoltenberg sagte
lediglich man solle nicht spekulieren
ja nicht spekulieren aber unsere
Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei der ARD und
derzeit liefern dann doch erstaunliche
Hintergrundinformationen detailreich
dazu bringen wir unsere Korrespondenten
mit dazu zunächst zu dir in Berlin was
kann man denn nach diesen Informationen
über den mutmaßlichen Hergang dieser
Aktion sagen ja das ist in Teilen schon
sehr detailliert was die Kollegen da
berichten danach soll es deutschen
Ermittlungsbehörden gelungen sein einen
Teil des tatvorgangs aufzuklären nämlich
vor allem die Frage mit welchem Boot ist
das Ganze ausgeführt worden es soll eine
Yacht gewesen sein die von einer Firma
angemietet wurde die zwei Ukraine gehört
diese Yacht soll in Rostock gestartet
sein dann über den Darß und über
Dänemark mit Zwischenstationen zum
Tatort gefahren sein und dort soll dann
die Tat eben von diesem Boot aus
koordiniert und begangen worden sein es
gibt sechs Personen die in diesem
Zusammenhang genannt werden ein Kapitän
Verbraucher zwei tauchassistenten und
eine Ärztin die den Sprengstoff
transportiert haben soll das ist also
alles schon sehr detailliert allein was
nicht klar zu sein scheint ist die
Identität dieser Personen denn es wurden
zwei Reisepässe gefunden die allerdings
professionell gefälscht waren und damit
gibt es zwar eine Verbindung in die
Ukraine durch die Firma die das Boot
angemietet hat aber eben noch keine
Klarheit darüber wer sich tatsächlich
hinter den Personen versteckt dann
bringen wir doch die USA mit rein MRT
wir sind unser Mann in Washington wir
hören jetzt immer eine
pro-ukrainische Gruppe könnte
möglicherweise dahinter stecken wer soll
denn das sein
ja die US-Behörden gehen offenbar seit
Monaten Hinweisen nach dass es
möglicherweise solch eine Gruppe gibt
die aus russischen putinengegnern und
ukrainischen Staatsbürgern besteht mit
losen Verbindungen zu den ukrainischen
Geheimdiensten diese Gruppe wird
zumindest verdächtigt Taten begangen zu
haben ohne Wissen und im auf ohne den
Auftrag der ukrainischen Regierung es
gibt ein Beispiel dafür im August
letzten Jahres explodierte eine Bombe
mitten in Moskau die Tochter eines
russischen Nationalisten Daria dougina
wurde dabei getötet und damals fanden
die USA Spuren darauf dass tatsächlich
solch eine Gruppe aktiv ist sie hat dann
Kiew gewarnt die US-Regierung sie sollte
das sofort unterbinden aber wenn eben es
tatsächlich sich um eine unabhängige
Gruppe handelt ist das natürlich
schwierig wir wissen nicht genau ob es
genau diese Gruppe ist die jetzt hinter
diesen Anschlägen auf Nord Stream
stecken könnte immer jetzt sind das
alles Geheimdienste Erkenntnisse
da wissen wir und auch in diesem Fall
ist es ja so du kannst dich oft genug
sagen das ist immer mit besonderer
Vorsicht zu genießen auf der anderen
Seite haben wir gerade noch mal das
Zitat von Joe Biden gehört dass er vor
dem Krieg gesagt hatte wir werden dem
Projekt Nord Stream ein Ende setzen ich
verspreche Ihnen dass wir es schaffen
werden kann man jetzt also zumindest von
einem ausgehen nämlich dass es zumindest
nicht Russland war oder wie valide sind
diese aktuellen Erkenntnisse
ja man kann noch keine
Schlussfolgerungen ziehen natürlich
hatte die Ukraine ein ganz hohes
Interesse sag mal im September daran
dass in einem möglicherweise harten
Winter niemand auf den Gedanken kommt
doch Gas aus dieser Pipeline zu nehmen
weder Deutschland noch andere die USA
sagen ganz kleinen solch einem Fall
hätte man dann mit Sanktionen reagiert
gegen jeden der dieses Gas genommen
hätte und sagt auch ganz klar die USA
hatten keinerlei Beteiligung an diesen
Anschlägen auf die Nord Stream Pipeline
man hält ja eine falls Flag Operation
für möglich also dass jemand den
Eindruck erwecken will dass die Ukraine
dahinter steckt möglicherweise hatte
Russland dieses Interesse um damit eben
die Regierung in Kiew zu diskreditieren
und das Bündnis unter Druck zu setzen
wir wissen oder gehen davon aus dass
vergangenen Freitag der Bundeskanzler
und der amerikanische Präsident Joe
Biden bei ihrem vier Augen Gespräch im
Weißen Haus über dieses Thema auch
geredet haben wie man mit diesen
Erkenntnissen dann umgehen würde also
noch sehr viele offene Fragen denn noch
die Frage natürlich an Dich jetzt nach
Berlin wenn sich bewahrheiten sollte
dass diese Sabotage einen pro
ukrainischen Hintergrund hat welche
Folgen hätte das denn dann für die
pro-okrainer Koalition im Westen und
auch für das Verhältnis zwischen Kiew
und Berlin das käme ganz darauf an ob
sich tatsächlich ein staatliche
ukrainischer Auftrag danach weisen lässt
und davon sind wir ja momentan von
dieser Schlussfolgerung sind wir
momentan noch relativ weit entfernt wäre
würde sich so etwas nachweisen lassen
wäre das mit Sicherheit ein massiver
vertrauensvertrauensverlust für selensky
und das würde das Verhältnis und die
Zusammenarbeit schon erschüttern
allerdings höre ich jetzt heute in allen
Gesprächen die ich geführt habe wo wir
natürlich auch mal nachgeholt haben wie
sind die Reaktionen jetzt auf diese
Informationen große Zurückhaltung weil
es eben überall heißt es ist noch keine
Schlussfolgerung möglich es sind noch
alle Varianten offen man muss jetzt
einmal die Ermittlungsergebnisse
abwarten es kommt also sehr darauf an
wie schnell und wie umfassen D der
Generalbundesanwalt und die Partner in
den anderen Ländern die mitermitteln zu
einem Ergebnis kommen und wie
transparent und umsichtig Sie dieses
Ergebnis tatsächlich dann auch
kommunizieren momentan sind hier alle
noch sehr zurückhaltend inklusive der
Bundesregierung die noch einmal darauf
verwiesen hat dass er eben der
Generalbundesanwalt noch ermittelt also
noch viel Vorsicht noch viel offen den
aktuellen Stand haben wir geschildert
mit eurer Hilfe herzlichen Dank ja und
immer
und wir müssen noch zu einem anderen
Thema kommen bei dem man aufhorcht der
Ton zwischen China und den USA wird
schärfer und feindseliger der starke
Mann in Peking Staats- und Parteichef
hijin Ping wirft den USA vor den
Aufstieg Chinas in der Welt verhindern
zu wollen und sein neuer Außenminister
legt nach und zwar ohne diplomatische
Zurückhaltung er wart die Amerikaner vor
katastrophalen Folgen vor Konflikt und
Konfrontation es geht um den Krieg gegen
die Ukraine es geht aber auch um
knallharte Wirtschaftsinteressen und
zwar auf beiden Seiten Miriam Steinhaus
Peking
Chinas Propaganda ist so simpel wie
eingängig die USA sind verantwortlich
für das Unheil in der Welt
solche Comics veröffentlichen Staats-
wenn die USA nicht auf die Bremse treten
sondern weiter auf dem falschen
wegfahren kann keine noch so große
Leitplanke das entgleisen verhindern
die konfliktliste zwischen den beiden
Ländern ist lang von Sanktionen gegen
Chinas Chiphersteller über die
ballonkrise bis zur Ukraine Chinas neuer
Außenminister zieht ein Vergleich zu
Taiwan er wirft den USA vor mit Waffen
auf der demokratischen Insel Kräfte zu
unterstützen die eine wie er es nennt
Abspaltung wollen
Chinas Volk hat jedes Recht zu fragen
warum die USA ausführlich über die
Souveränität und die territoriale
Integrität in der Ukraine sprechen
während sie Chinas Souveränität und
territoriale Integrität in der
taiwanfrage missachten
China betrachtet Taiwan als Teil seines
Staatsgebiets spricht seit Jahren von
Wiedervereinigung dabei gehörte Taiwan
nie zur heutigen Volksrepublik vor dem
Außenminister attackierte auch
Parteichefin selbst die USA mit
ungewöhnlich klaren Worten
insbesondere die westlichen Länder
angeführt von den USA verfolgen eine
umfassende Eindämmung Einkreisung und
Unterdrückung Chinas
Peking sendet diese Botschaften vor
allem nach innen sie sollen das eigene
Volk auf schwere Zeiten einschwören und
zusammenhalten Menschen bis zum
Heilbronn der 45-Jährige handelt mit
Autozubehör und Metallwaren verkauft
hauptsächlich nach Russland gerade läuft
es sehr gut weil wegen der Sanktion des
Westens viele europäische Produkte
fehlen
eigentlich ist der Markt gesättigt aber
wenn zum Beispiel Deutschland nicht mehr
verkauft gibt es eine Lücke Produkte aus
China können dieses Loch füllen
während Chinas Wirtschaft versucht sich
von drei Jahren Null Corvette Politik zu
erholen schrumpft der Handel mit dem
Westen weiter den mit russland baut
Peking aus in der Fabrik von sunravos
Zulieferer produzieren sie
Hydraulikzylinder für den Straßenbau
ja das geht alles nach Russland weil ihr
eure Sachen ja nicht mehr nach Russland
verkauft
ein Grund warum China weiter an Russland
Seite steht denn die Kommunistische
Partei hat ihrem Volk versprochen wir
sorgen dafür dass es Euch besser geht
wenn das nicht mehr geht wenn die
Wirtschaft lahmt hat die Führung ein
legitimitätsproblem
es ist die große Weltpolitik die uns
hier heute beschäftigt und ihre ganz
konkreten Auswirkungen so wie die USA im
Kalten Krieg das in Deutschland hatten
so stellt sich auch Litauen einen
dauerhaften militärischen Schutz vor und
zwar durch die Deutschen die Angst dort
sitzt tief dass auch die baltischen
Staaten eines Tages einen russischen
Angriff abzuwehren haben könnten die
Bundeswehr ist bereits im Land heute ist
auch der Bundesverteidigungsminister auf
Besuch bei den Einheiten die dort die
Ostflanke der NATO sichern sollen und es
ist kein einfacher Besuch ob es wirklich
deutlich mehr Soldaten werden aus
Deutschland da ist Boris Pistorius
auffällig zurückhaltend denn
Deutschlands Streitkräfte haben ihre
eigenen Probleme aus Vilnius instrums
Anfahrt im Boxer durch den eiskalten
Wald von Litauen die Grenze zu Belarus
gerade mal 15 km entfernt es ist der
erste Besuch von Verteidigungsminister
Pistorius bei einem Auslandseinsatz er
führt ihn an die Ostflanke für ihn gilt
die Sicherheit Litauens ist auch unsere
Sicherheit
1990 war die Bundesrepublik Deutschland
die Ostflanke wie unsere Sicherheit
wurde gewährleistet durch die Nato und
ihre Verbündeten und heute ist eben
Polen das Baltikum und andere Länder die
Ostflanke und deswegen sind wir heute
genauso in der Verpflichtung diesen
Schutz zu gewährleisten wie das die NATO
damals für uns getan
Übung der Panzergrenadierbrigade
Vorpommern der Minister mittendrin sie
üben die Abwehr eines möglichen
russischen Angriffs es gilt
Verteidigungsbereitschaft zu
demonstrieren abzuschrecken doch geht
das Abschreckung angesichts des
Materialmangels bei der Bundeswehr erst
gestern berichtete das ZDF das
Deutschland auch für die schnelle
Eingreiftruppe wie JTF der NATO nicht
die geforderten Leopard-Panzer stellen
können sie mussten aus unterschiedlichen
Einheiten gezogen werden wir haben keine
ausrüstungsmenge bei den Leoparden den
muss ich sehr deutlich widersprechen wir
hatten einen Stau bei der Wartung und
Instandsetzung der wird jetzt aufgelöst
aber werden wir haben waren jederzeit in
der entstanden
und das ist kein zusammen glauben wie
ich heute morgen gelesen habe das ist
normales Management der Ressourcen wenn
Fahrzeuge ausfallen oder nicht schnell
genug gewartet werden können werden sie
durch andere gleichwertige Fahrzeuge
ersetzt dass wir sehen ist dass die
Bundeswehr insgesamt als
Gesamtorganisation tatsächlich nicht in
der Lage ist auf Überraschungen zu
reagieren sondern nur mit ganz ganz
kleinen Teilen tatsächlich einsatzbereit
zu sein und damit sind wir weit davon
entfernt dass wir unsere NATO zu sagen
einhalten in die bedeuten nicht nur in
dem Video ETF zu stellen sondern dass
die Bundeswehr insgesamt tatsächlich
Kampf und kriegsfähig ist die Bundeswehr
kämpft mit Personal und
Materialproblemen während die
nato-anforderungen stetig wachsen wohl
auch deshalb reagiert Pistorius
zögerlich auf die Forderung seines
litauischen Amtskollegen eine von Berlin
zugesagte Brigade mit bis zu 5000
Soldaten dauerhaft in Litauen zu
stationieren statt nur zu Übungen
anreisen zu lassen
die geographische Lage der baltischen
Staaten erfordert eine stärkere Präsenz
der Bündnispartner in der Region um eine
zuverlässige Abschreckung und vorne
Verteidigung zu gewährleisten
und von der
Flexibilität der das richtige eine feste
Brigade im Baltikum oder mehrere oder
ist es besser zum Schutz der gesamten
Ostflanke über flexible Einheit
nachzudenken wir sind NATO steht vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium in Vilnius in
ihrer Angst vor Russland setzen die
Litauer auf Verbündete und fordern mehr
Schutz Deutschland wird sich dazu
verhalten müssen
und du Hannah hast jetzt eine erste
Nachrichtenübersicht heute Abend ja oder
blicken wir zuerst einmal auf das
deutsche chinesische Verhältnis die
Bundesregierung will nämlich die
chinesische Technik überprüfen lassen
die im deutschen 5g Mobilfunknetz
verbaut wurde dabei geht es laut einem
Sprecher des Innenministeriums um
mögliche sicherheits- und
missbrauchsrisiken auch mit Blick auf
vertrauliche Kommunikation die USA haben
Netztechnik von chinesischen Herstellern
wie Huawei bereits aus ihren Märkten
ausgeschlossen Washington hat den
Konzern als Gefahr für die nationale
Sicherheit eingestuft
zum Auftakt ihres viertägigen Besuchs im
Irak hat Außenministerin bärburg dem
Land weitere Unterstützung im Kampf
gegen die terrormiliz islamischer Staat
zugesagt der is bleibe eine Bedrohung
sagte sie nach einem Treffen mit ihrem
irakischen Amtskollegen Hussein deshalb
sei auch deutsche Soldatinnen und
Soldaten zur Beratung der
Sicherheitskräfte im Irak der Bock wird
auch das kurdische Autonomiegebiet im
Norden des Landes besuchen wo die
Bundeswehrsoldaten stationiert sind
nach dem Vergiftungsfällen an
medienschulen hat das iranische
Innenministerium erste Festnahmen von
Tatverdächtigen in fünf Provinzen
gemeldet unterdessen gingen in mehreren
iranischen Städten Lehrkräfte und
Angehörige auf die Straße und darf in
den Behörden vor nicht ausreichend gegen
die Vergiftungen vorzugehen die ersten
Fälle wurden im November gemeldet
betroffen sind mehrere tausend Kinder
und Jugendliche
Deutschland hat bis Freitag mehr als
1.300 Visa für Betroffene der
Erdbebenkatastrophe in der Türkei und in
Syrien ausgestellt das erklärte heute
ein Sprecher des Auswärtigen Amtes damit
hat sich die Zahl binnen einer Woche
mehr als verdoppelt fast
1.100 Visa wurden nach dem vereinfachten
Verfahren erteilt dass die
Bundesregierung kurz nach der
Katastrophe angekündigt hatte
bei einem israelischen Militäreinsatz im
Westjordanland sind mindestens sechs
Palästinenser getötet worden zudem
wurden laut palästinensischen Angaben
mindestens 16 Personen verletzt Israels
Ministerpräsidenten Eltern Yahoo
erklärte einer der Getöteten sei an der
Ermordung zweier jüdischer Siedler Ende
Februar beteiligt gewesen Gewalt
zwischen Israelis und Palästinensern war
in den vergangenen Wochen immer wieder
eskaliert
wegen eines geplanten Mediengesetzes ist
es in Georgien zu gewaltsamen
Massenprotesten gekommen die Polizei in
Tiflis setzte Tränen Gas und
Wasserwerfer ein auf beiden Seiten habe
es Verletzte gegeben tausende
protestierten gegen das heute vom
Parlament in erster Lesung gebilligte
Gesetz dass sie für Pro russisch halten
es sieht unter anderem vor Medien als
ausländische Agenten einzustufen wenn
sie zu mehr als 20% aus dem Ausland
finanziert werden
bei unseren Nachbarn in Frankreich ging
heute nicht mehr viel auf den Bahnhöfen
den Flughäfen in den Schulen und an den
Tankstellen dafür mehr als 250
Demonstrationen überall im Land sie
gelten dem Mann im elisee Präsident
Emmanuel macron hat eine Rentenreform
zum zentralen innenpolitischen Ziel
seiner zweiten Amtszeit erklärt sonst
sei das bisherige Rentensystem nicht
mehr zu bezahlen
hunderttausende heute auf den
französischen Straßen sehen das anders
die Protestbewegung sie wird immer
größer erfasst jung und alt und richtet
sich längst nicht mehr rein gegen die
Reform des Rentensystems Megane treibt
wie hunderttausende Französinnen und
Franzosen heute der Frust über macrons
Politik auf die Straße
uns reicht es wirklich neben der Reform
geht es auch gegen eine Regierung die
nur auf die Reichen und deren Dividenden
blickt und alle anderen Leute ihrem
Elend überlässt das regt uns auf
die Regierung indes zieht das Vorhaben
weiter durch derzeit wird es im Senat
beraten doch an der geplanten Anhebung
des Rentenbeginns von 62 auf 64 Jahre
gibt es kein Röteln in einer immer älter
werdenden Gesellschaft sei die Reform
unumgänglich sonst drohe ein Defizit in
der Rentenkasse
vor allem um die Renten der Wald 20
Millionen Rentner in Frankreich
verlässlich finanzieren zu können und
das ohne auch nur einen Euro der
Kaufkraft einzubüßen die Steuern zu
erhöhen oder die Renten zu kürzen das
bedeutet dass wir alle ein bisschen
länger arbeiten müssen
doch genau daran entzündet sich der
Konflikt die früher Rente gilt seit den
80ern als
kämpfte soziale Errungenschaft hat eine
enorme Symbolkraft in Frankreich so
enorm dass viele bereit sind das
landzulegen für die kommenden Tage sind
weitere Streiks etwa im Transportwesen
und Energiesektor angekündigt
die Macht der Gewerkschaften das Land zu
blockieren wird nun beim Ringen mit der
Regierung eine entscheidende Rolle
spielen sie haben 2019 bereits gezeigt
dass sie zu langfristigen Blockaden
durchaus in der Lage sind damals wurden
sie von der Öffentlichkeit unterstützt
was ich nun wieder abzuzeichnen
scheintine tatsächlich lehnt eine
Mehrheit die Reform ab fürchtet ein
zunehmend leistungsorientiertes
Gesellschaftsmodell vor allem
Geringverdiener mit körperlich
anstrengenden Jobs fühlen sich abgehängt
sehen sich nicht in der Lage so lange zu
arbeiten
die Arbeitslosigkeit und später fällt
ihre Rente dann geringer aus weil sie
nicht lange genug eingezahlt haben sie
werden also doppelt bestraft
soziale Gerechtigkeit fordern sie auf
ihren Plakaten und spätestens heute wird
klar den Kampf geben Sie so schnell
nicht auf am Wochenende wollen Sie
erneut auf die Straße gehen
es ist im Grunde jedes Jahr das gleiche
und das genau ist vielleicht das größte
Problem dass es eben jedes Jahr das
gleiche ist heute ist er wieder da der
Tag des Jahres bis zu dem statistisch
gesehen alle Frauen in diesem Land
gratis arbeiten wenn man sie mit Männern
vergleicht eben weil sie im Schnitt
deutlich schlechter bezahlt werden als
ihre Kollegen der Unterschied beträgt in
Deutschland 18 Prozent alles genau
errechnet also der Tag hat sogar einen
Namen Equal Pay Day nur konkrete
versuche etwas zu ändern diesen Tag also
überflüssig zu machen stecken immer noch
in den Anfängen und kommen nicht recht
vom Fleck warum das so ist zeigt
Henriette de maizier
Lohnlücke schließen Equal Pay Day es
scheint eine verzagte Kundgebung ohne
richtigen Adressaten ein aufgeteiltes
Brot das die Komplexität der
Ungerechtigkeit versinnbildlichen soll
18 Prozent das ist die Entgeltlücke das
ist der heutige Status Quo und seit
Aufzeichnung dieser Entgeltlücke in
Deutschland vor 17 Jahren ist diese
Entgeltlücke gerade mal um 5%
geschrumpft der Grund Frauen wählen
häufiger schlechter bezahlte Berufe
Arbeiten mehr in Teilzeit und in weniger
qualifizierten Jobs Kritik von der
antidekriminierungsbeauftragten wir
haben in Deutschland tatsächlich
in vielen Bereichen immer noch ich kann
es nicht anders sagen vor sind flutliche
Klischees was Männer und Frauen angeht
und auch was Erwerbsarbeit und gute
Erwerbsarbeit angeht und da ist es so
dass eben viele Berufe in den Frauen
sind als nicht so wertvoll betrachtet
werden und eben nicht so gut bezahlt
werden Beruf in den Männer sind es soll
sich was ändern wurde im
Koalitionsvertrag 2021 vereinbart wir
wollen die Lohnlücke zwischen Frauen und
Männern schließen das Problem Komplex
entscheidend auch das Thema
Familiengründung können Frauen zu Beginn
des Erwerbslebens Männer beim Gehalt
fast einholen fallen sie im Schnitt ab
dem 30 lebensjahr oft mit dem ersten
Kind zurück Einschnitte die Frauen bis
zur Rente nicht wieder aufholen die
gender paygap von 18 Prozent es brauche
eine bessere Vereinbarkeit von Beruf und
Familie damit Vollzeitarbeit möglich ist
der Bundesarbeitsminister stellt fest
Frauen arbeiten in vielen Bereichen in
die Tarifbindung schwach ist und da
müssen wir ansetzen wenn eine
Mindestlohn erhöht das hat schon
geholfen aber wir brauchen wieder mehr
Tarifbindung zwischen Arbeitgebern und
Gewerkschaften denn da wo Tarife sind
sind Löhne gerechter und angemessener
außerdem soll das jetzt geltende Lohn
Transparenzgesetz reformiert werden auch
in Unternehmen mit weniger als 200
Mitarbeitenden soll es künftig Auskunft
darüber geben ob männliche Kollegen mehr
verdienen geplant ist außerdem ein
Verbandsklagerecht gefordert wird jedoch
noch mehr im Moment sind die Auskünfte
die man dadurch bekommt die sind zu
gering es ist zu kompliziert es ist für
Frauen zu anstrengend eigentlich müsste
das ja umgekehrt werden also unternehmen
müssen beweisen dass sie tatsächlich
gleich bezahlen das wäre die richtige
Ausrichtung was verdient die Frau dabei
geht es auch um Gleichstellung um
Gerechtigkeit für die Frauen aber auch
für die ganze Gesellschaft
Deutschlands größter wohnungskonzern wo
novia hat heute Besuch von der
Staatsanwaltschaft Bochum bekommen
mehrere Büros des DAX Unternehmens
wurden unter durchsucht und vier
Beschuldigte festgenommen Stefanie
Barrett es geht um Korruptionsverdacht
was sind die genauen Vorwürfe ja ganz
konkret wird vonovia Mitarbeitern
vorgeworfen bei der Auftragsvergabe
Firmen bevorzugt und dafür im Gegenzug
geld oder Sachleistungen erhalten zu
haben auch handwerkertätigkeiten sollen
abgerechnet worden sein die niemals
ausgeführt wurden und das Ausmaß ist
nicht ganz unerheblich neben der
Bochumer zentrale durchsuchten Ermittler
bei der groß angelegten Razzia mehr als
40 privat und Geschäftsräume in
Nordrhein-Westfalen Baden-Württemberg
Hamburg Sachsen dabei wurden vier
Haftbefehle vollstreckt der
immobilienriese besitzt knapp 550.000
Wohnungen in Deutschland Schweden und
Österreich und gibt jedes Jahr
Milliarden für mehr Modernisierung und
Instandhaltung der Gebäude aus der
Konzern sieht sich als Geschädigter und
will nun bei den Ermittlungen
vollkooperieren stellt sich nun die
Frage wie hoch der finanzielle Schaden
für das Unternehmen tatsächlich ist für
die Aktie lässt sich dieser heute
bereits klar beziffern mit einem Minus
von 5,6% waren wohnovia Papiere hier in
Frankfurt Schlusslicht im deutschen
Aktienbarometer den DAX bremste heute
zudem der US-Notenbankchef aus Jerome
Paul kündigte nämlich am Nachmittag
unmissverständlich an er sei bereit die
Zinsen weiter zu erhöhen um die
Inflation zu stoppen höhere US-Zinsen
stärken den Dollar der Euro musste daher
Federn lassen vielen Dank Stefanie nach
Frankfurt
Japans Raumfahrtprogramm hat einen
weiteren Rückschlag erlitten der Staat
einer neuen Träger Rakete ist erneut
gescheitert verhob die Rakete zunächst
planmäßig ab doch der Antrieb der
zweiten Raketenstufe zündete nicht die
japanische Raumfahrtbehörde
jagdverordnete deshalb die selbst
Zerstörung an schon Mitte Februar war
der erste Staat versucht der Rakete
aufgrund eines elektronikfehlers
abgebrochen worden
der Schauspieler heinz Baumann ist tot
wie seine Agentur mitteilte ist der
bereits am Samstag im Alter von 95
Jahren gestorben als
Kriminalhauptkommissar jeweils Strobel
spielte er an der Seite von Evelyn
Hamann in der ARD Krimiserie Adelheid
und ihre Mörder zuvor ermittelte er zwei
Jahrzehnte in der zdf-produktion so hoch
5113 oh man trat noch bis in die 2000er
Jahre hinein regelmäßig in
TV-Produktionen auf
der britische Stararchitekt david
schipperfield ist mit dem renommierten
pritzka Preis für Architektur
ausgezeichnet worden der für seine
minimalistischen und eleganten Entwürfe
bekannte Architekt hat wiederholt auch
in Deutschland gearbeitet so war er
maßgeblich an der Restaurierung und
Gestaltung der Berliner Museumsinsel
beteiligt am Wiederaufbau des neuen
Museums auch die Sanierung der Neuen
Nationalgalerie zählt zu seinen arbeiten
ja er wird heute feiern denn das ist
sowas wieder Nobelpreis für Architekten
so wir empfehlen Ihnen jetzt noch die 37
Grad Reportage gleich nach uns
Wanderschäfer das ist ja so ein Beruf
bei dem die einen ins Träumen geraten
und die anderen Fragen gibt's die noch
es gibt sie und wir können sie alle
gemeinsam gleich begleiten wie sie mit
Leidenschaft kämpfen für den Erhalt
ihres Traumberufs gleich nach uns
so wir sagen DANKE für heute und gerne
bis morgen ja und gegen 0:30 Uhr gibt es
unser heute journal Update mit Nazan
gökdemann tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend das stürmische tief
kornelies hat inzwischen das Baltikum
erreicht und morgen zieht entlang dieser
Luftmassengrenze ein kleines Tief
schnell von West nach Ost über
Deutschland hinweg es bringt Schnee mit
Schnee fällt aber auch schon heute Nacht
fünf bis zehn in der Eifel sogar an die
20 cm Neuschnee können bis morgen früh
zusammen kommen das wird den Verkehr
behindert einige Schneeschauer gibt's
heute Nacht auch in Schleswig-Holstein
die Temperaturen sinken auf plus 3 bis
-4 Grad und morgen liegen sie in
Norddeutschland bei drei bis fünf Grad
im Süden wird es deutlich milder mit 9
bis 13 Grad in der Mitte allerdings hier
in Rheinland-Pfalz Nordrhein-Westfalen
in Hessen Thüringen und Sachsen liegen
die Höchstwerte bei 0 bis 3 Grad das ist
genau der Bereich in dem sie sich morgen
Früh und am Vormittag noch auf
gefährliche Glätte einstellen müssen
denn dort schneit es im Laufe des Tages
steigt die Schneefallgrenze an dann wird
immer mehr Schneeregen aus dem Schnee im
Süden fällt kräftiger Regen und im
Norden wird es ganz freundlich mit
einzelnen Schneeschauer und dann kommt
die Nacht zum Donnerstag und da kommt
gleich das nächste Tief hinterher das
auch wieder über die Mitte und den Süden
Deutschlands ostwärts zieht wenn Sie
also bisher noch nicht so viel Regen in
Süddeutschland abbekommen haben dann
schauen Sie sich hier die Entwicklung an
denn auch in Baden-Württemberg und in
Bayern wird es dann kräftig regnen der
Donnerstag insgesamt ist also ruhiger am
Freitag und Samstag schüttet es dann im
Westen und im Süden weiter ergiebig und
dazu wird es windiger tschüss